serge letchimy député de la martinique à
président des assises de l'outre-mer
pour le transport aérien
des assises qui se sont terminés en fin
de semaine dernière par la ministre du
secteur elisabeth bornes
bonjour serge letchimy bonjour plusieurs
mois de réflexion avec de vraies pistes
de travail pour nos pays à travers ces
assises pas seulement des réflexions ce
sont des propositions très concrètes
depuis une grande partie de ces
propositions retenues par la ministre
puisque nous avons finalisé des assises
lors d'une grande réunion à paris et sur
les douze propositions que nous avons
pas et faites y avions aux quatre qui
ont été retenus et d'autres qui sont en
chantier
alors parmi ces pistes vous savez la
première qui vient l'idée de tout aux
martiniquais de tout antillo guyanais
c'est le prix du billet est ce que les
autorités ont envie de comprendre qu'il
ya forcément quelque chose à faire je
veux répondre à la question mais
permettez moi de dire ce qui a été
retenu est déjà si vous permet d c'est
pour moi importante et nous avons la
première chose très importante c'est que
il y aura désormais des possibilités de
négocier territoire par territoire
bassin maritime par bassin maritime
c'est à dire l'océan indien pour la
réunion pour les vite la caraïbe
martinique guadeloupe guyane d'été sur
n'avait les arrangements administratifs
en termes de droits de trafic très
important à dire aujourd'hui si vous
voulez qu'ils aient liaison qui sait ce
talent entre martinique jamaïque ou
trinidad où l'argentine où l'europe et
l'amérique
il faut absolument passer par une
procédure extrêmement longue donc ces
arrangements administratifs ont permis
de gagner un temps considérable
la france pourra négocier avec le
mexique le réduire à cesser la dg assez
local pour avoir des accords techniques
administratifs pouvoir décidé d'assurer
une liaison possible et ne pas remonter
systématiquement à paris dans les
accords dits de thé nation qui implique
l'europe mais c'est très important
deuxième chose il y aura une conférence
annuelle aérien qui va réunir l'ensemble
des acteurs économiques à la fois l'état
représenté par le préfet la collectivité
territoriale de martinique mais aussi
des acteurs économiques la personne
qu'on puisse asseoir des synergies le
décision parce que si vous faites
désenclavement aérienne de grande
puissance
il faut que le territoire soit
suffisamment
m pour accueillir des personnes guéries
fonctionner ce sera fait et d'autres
décisions très importantes
vous savez lorsqu'un étranger en europe
arrive en europe
sept étrangers deux roues avant un autre
visage pour arriver en martinique sé
supprimés et puis je pense que ces
quatre ou cinq propositions sont très
intéressants terrestre doute à gagner
dont ce que vous avez dit oui j'ai
assisté par s'éteint c'est le prix du
billet ça n'a pas de prix lui asséna
lycée c'est un sujet qui a été traitée
nous avons fait une proposition des
propositions très concrètes
parce qu'il ya deux pistes la première
puis s'est accélérée ce qu'on appelle la
compétition la compétitivité entre
compagnies ouvrir le ciel
la deuxième piste aussi regarder segment
par segment comment nous pouvons
maîtriser des coûts parce que c'est la
question de six unités
il avait un billet qui peut être 300 400
euros pendant une période dite creuse et
bien vous avez des billets pendant les
périodes dans ce qui peut être 1000 1200
euros là vous parlez de carrie fort de
france paris fort de france
donc là la ministre est engagée à ses
guichets le mystère l'outre-mer à
travers un travail de terrain computer
comment le mieux réguler les prix plus
particulièrement pour les personnes qui
bénéficient de l'aide aux déplacements
mais nous n'avons pas encore les
réponses reçues mayenne problème à
travers ce que vous avez indiquée c'est
le prix du billet pour un exemple chez
nous f régional au cap et près de milo
elle est coiffée trois fois puis biya
voile en france
elisabeth baume a quand même entendu ce
chiffre que vous lui avez donné elle a
entendu et là aussi avant de la lui m et
300 euros déjà pour un personnage et pas
seulement barreau chief ceci vous donner
un chiffre
c'est sympa mais il faut la solution
derrière je pense très honnêtement et
j'ai posé le problème très clairement
qu'il faut absolument pour les liaisons
infra dom martinique guadeloupe guyane
et vous n'avez pas parlé le martinique
guadeloupe et du miellat vieux passé de
100 euros à 200 euros à peu près friser
les 300 euros et oui c'est vrai il ya
certainement à mettre en place pour le
désenclavement entre dom entre mayotte
et la réunion entre martin et guadeloupe
et bien trouver les solutions
d'organisation de service public de
telle sorte qu'on puisse répondre à
cette continuité territoriale
nécessaires au développement économique
du secteur
alors était en face de la ministre la
semaine dernière
serge letchimy est ce qu elle a évoqué
un agenda pour que tout que vous ayez un
début de réponse de choses concrètes
face à ces à ces pistes que vous avez
avancé et nous avons déjà des réponses
très concrètes par rapport aux quatre
éléments que j'ai vu tout à l'heure ça
c'est fait ce sera amusant mais
maintenant il nous reste d'autres
d'autres problèmes il ya le prix des
billets d'avion l'âme indiqué la mise en
place d'organisations service public
pour pouvoir désenclaver en interne mais
aussi en interne de certains pays comme
la guyane la guyane c'est l'équivalent
du portugal en surface et pour faire
paris et cayenne maripa soula
ce sont des conditions infra
structurelles qui sont pas acceptables
en matière d'infrastructures
aéroportuaires
et puis il nous reste bien sûr d'autres
problèmes qui sont des irritants
incroyable quand vous partez de fort de
france
vous arrivez la double peine double
peine et le double contrôle vous êtes
contrôlés ici en partant et vous arrivez
sans escale ou contrôler quand même bon
c'est aussi nobel qui fait agresser
humiliant en plus il n'y a pas
d'explication
l'explication de lire un petit peu la
réalité
elle a découvert ça le ministre cet
homme a découvert bien entendu de ma
voix dire clairement écouter faut pas
taxer les puces ces pays là comme si des
pays où on craint qu'ils arrivaient de
drôles d'autres comme ça ça n'a pas ça
n'a pas de sens aujourd'hui
si le travail est fait quoique tout -
martinique on devrait pas avoir ce type
de problèmes à ce type de qu'un plat
donc la solution ce serait de en
attendant de supprimer ça je pense que
c'est une décision politique que le
premier ministre veut répandre cette
décision n'est pas encore prise
nous avons émis la solution de voir sur
un peu les systèmes de paraphes
c'est à dire de le présentation dans le
numérique l'organisation automatique de
la délivrance du ca existe ailleurs qui
ça fonctionne très bien c'est là
fonctionne très bien il suffit
simplement non pas de bouleverser
schengen parce que s'allier
d'après ce qu'ils disent ou fait que la
martinique guadeloupe guyane tout ça
sont pas dans l'espace schengen et qui à
se comprendre nécessaire ça permettra
d'assurer la fluidité ne pas subir cette
humiliation
alors la première fois que vous étiez
avec nos serge chibi pour évoquer ces
assises du transport aérien
vous avez quand même insisté sur quelque
chose de très important pour vous la
filière aéronautique a développé pour
nos pays et vous parlait même de centre
de formation de haut niveau alors c'est
juste une idée en l'air ou bien lente y
ait des choses vont se mettre sur pied
très inquiet brady des douze
propositions
je pense qu'il y à un centre formation
de haut niveau bien sûr je propose que
ce soit d'un secteur caraïbes et
deuxième manche pour tout que ce soit en
martinique
vous savez la chose la plus importante
pour nous c'est d'avoir une
reconnaissance une qualification de haut
niveau le fait de mettre un centre de
formation de pilotes de ligne de
mécaniciens art martinique
ça pourrait permettre à des milliers de
personnes de venir se faire former en
martinique ça peut être pas seulement
les audio guides et autres ça se dessine
est d'ailleurs à la réunion et
réunionnais sont entrain de mai fait
renaître leur propre centre de formation
aujourd'hui et on a une espèce de de
renforcement de moyens grâce aux
alliances qu'il n'y avait pas d' agace
car l'afrique du sud on pourrait
vraiment créer une vraie dynamique de
fédérations d'initiatives autour des
métiers de l'aérien
c'est pas seulement le pilote et le
mécanicien celui achètent des pièces etc
et avoir des gens les états unis et du
brésil je sais déjà qu'il veut se
promener site et donc la vision n'est
pas arrêté aujourd'hui définitivement
parce que ça demande une et qu'elle est
glauque et l'écho non et gestion très
bons échos positifs vous savez ça j'ai
subi dès que martiniquais et vaut
quelque chose pour la martinique savez
qu'il ya une rivalité régionale qui
s'installe au tout de suite
non répond cyclotron doué pour la cité
du rhum et maintenant vous craignez pas
un concurrent c'est un manque de
réactivité de notre part sur i télé
c'est parce qu'on n'a pas suffisamment
d'intelligence eu le courage de
détermination de faire ce que nous avons
inscrit c'est totalement lamentable ce
qui s'est passé pour le cyclotron et
c'est pas de la faute des guadeloupéens
de se montrer plus actif que nous c'est
se de notre de notre
responsabilité où on a complètement tué
le projet pour des idées purement
politique c'est construire cette école
de formation pilote vous y croyez et
sachez quoi si les martiniquais mène le
combat pour sont installés dans le pays
alors ces assises du transport aérien
étant terminée espère une sorte de
service après vente
est ce qu'il y aura un suivi de ce
qu'ils étaient
annoncée qui a été retenu oui on a
discuté de ça j'ai discuté s'aplatit
québec madame la ministre isabel board
et nous avons convenu tous les deux je
peux le dire qui et l'on rencontre qui
se fera avec le ministère de l'outre-mer
et une équipe pour pouvoir mettre en
place ce qui est décidé je l'indiquais
tout à l'heure et continuer à travailler
sur les solutions plus technique et
peut-être plus complexe à mettre en
oeuvre le centre de formation ça demande
la mobilisation unis c'est à la
recherche de l'éducation pour définir le
site pour travailler ensemble et à voir
l'emplacement nécessaire parce que parce
que ce qu'on redoute le plus aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on ait fait ces assises qui de
très bons rapports qu'ils soient sortis
et puis que vous n'avez finalement ça se
termine dans un tiroir à côté c'est une
question d'honnêteté intellectuelle du
gouverneur actuel j'ai accepté très
honnêtement de me mettre au service de
ses différents pays d'outre-mer
d'apporter ma contribution pour faire
douze propositions
la ministre de sa bouche a déclaré qu'à
quatre propositions qui sont retenus je
les ai indiqué ayez son camp cinq ou six
propositions à affiner simon n'a pas vos
responsabilités et puis il dit il pas
les épis pas métier en oeuvre
c'est pas à moi qu'il faut bouger ça
c'est plutôt chaque mot nova respecte
engagement à quoi je pense qu'elle donne
c'est une femme honnête je pense qu'elle
respectera son engagement
la seule chose il faut qu'on soit
vigilant je le serai de telle sorte que
je puisse revendiquer demander exiger
evo et d'autres partis nick et d'autres
martiniquais et que ce que nous avons
convenu soit mis sur pied ici en
réussissant nous réussit n'est avancée
considérable pour nous en martinique en
guadeloupe à la réunion simplement parce
que les akans mayence est pas un luxe
c'est aussi la continuité territoriale
mais c'est aussi à mon avis le vecteur
qui pourrait nous permettre de pouvoir
trouver d'autres orientations
économiques et mieux nous connecter par
rapport à notre environnement c'est
anormal qu'on soit une île et qu'on soit
complètement ignorants absent dans les
quotas qu'on pourrait avoir que la
plupart des pays à 35 pays d'outre-mer
ces 12 millions et d'autres étant telle
pays deal dans la caraïbe c'est 50
aéroports
le nombre de passagers par an sous
l'ensemble de lomé à ses 12 millions de
passagers et ses quatre mille
de passagers dans la relation et ce
plafond est aussi un vrai un véritable
enjeu économique pour nous merci serge
letchimy député de la martinique
président des assises de l'outre-mer le
transport et merci d'avoir été ce matin
bercy avec d'eau dans son crédit bonne
journée